[Music]
18:22 seven late the first half much to
throw again well protected good coverage
this time able to extend the play and a
man comes free turtle Citarum ball using
his speed in the endzone for the
touchdown
creativity the quarterback Lafitte
number the Bruins on the ground
Rambow just breaks that round off first
and goal at the one servant
touchdown oh you hurt is not a small man
third and seven
[Applause]
kitchen catch sermon touchdown
no Jo within a mile
there's one thing to say that it's
another thing to do it against these
Oklahoma players as good as any broken
CD
send to the end zone two catches for the
freshman Hazelwood
the pressures from grant story and the
lakes to the dance
it's the defense second at six at the 40
it's off his back
nice throw CD
13-yard touchdown but look at the touch
Hertz back to throw looking deep
Charleston rainbow touchdown Oklahoma a
play-action shot for a 39 yard touchdown
[Applause]
option to the right that hurts fakes the
pitch he scores the tip stick
jaylen hurts with his second rushing
touchdown today they had about 20 guys
were being
Bhaiji one school
that's pretty much back to
[Applause]
[Music]
he run straight ahead
makes the move gets the force down in
the touchdown Jalen hurts from 30 yards
in Oklahoma strikes quickly what up at
you boy Adam left coach you like that
content I know you like that content hit
subscribe for more of it from Bleacher
Report